Chinese airlines are not heading in a
good direction it's no secret that
currently we are facing a worldwide
shortage of pilots and as we move
forward this shortage is only getting
larger with China being at the center of
a growing need for air transportation
China's need for pilots has skyrocketed
over the past couple of years as a
result in order to attract foreign
policy into China many airlines in China
are paying very well oftentimes salary
start at $300,000 for first officers and
go up to $500,000 for seasoned captain's
and on top of this the entire income is
completely tax-free as in they'll pay
for income taxes considering that even
the biggest players in the aviation
industry have quite slim profit margins
of about 10% how are these airlines able
to pay about double the salary as
standard airline would pay and still
make money well as you would expect the
answer is that most of them don't make
money in the last quarter of 2018 only
six of the top 20 Asian airlines were
able to turn over a profit but this is
not due to a lack of demand the demand
for air travel is at an all-time high
and exponentially growing moving forward
despite this increased demand air fares
have fallen flat and continue to
decrease as more competition moves in so
why are Chinese airlines facing this
problem well starting off Chinese
airlines are competing in an
oversaturated market
China has eight major airlines and 34
minor airlines of which 12 opened up in
the past six years to put this in
perspective the US only has 13 passenger
airlines in total that classify as minor
or major airlines whether the demand
matches up or not the sheer number of
airlines is prone to start a bidding war
to bottom and that is exactly what we
have seen despite increased fuel prices
despite increased demand and despite
increased pilot pay or the past couple
of years Chinese air fares have
continued to drop this is because all
the new minor airlines are willing to
lose money the first decade or so an
operation to carve out a portion of
market share when there are eight
dominate
in a region the only way from minor
airlines to stand out and attract
customers is to undercut the competition
as several minor airlines constantly
fight each other for lower fares the
major airlines are forced to follow and
give up their profit or risk giving up a
big portion of their customers to minor
airlines rapidly expanding fleets so
larger Chinese airlines not only have to
sell their tickets for very low profit
or even at a loss to compete with minor
airlines but they also have to
constantly increase their pilot salaries
to keep their pilots as well as
attracting new pilots and this is a pond
we are seeing right now constantly
increasing expenses and constantly
decreasing profit despite constantly
increasing revenue from the increased
traffic furthermore this issue doesn't
seem to be slowing anytime soon as
analyst estimated China will need
between 4,000 and 5,000 new airline
pilots every year for the next two
decades despite all of these issues in
the Chinese market six Airlines did work
around the problem and still managed to
profit so how do they do it well it's
not higher ticket prices as one of the
profitable airlines was Air Asia a
budget airline leading a path in
reducing ticket prices often times
budget carriers in America make their
money from selling amenities and not the
ticket itself for instance they might
charge hefty fees for baggage seats
election food and even checking you in
at the airport but for Air Asia even all
of these are not enough to make up for
the steeply discounted flight tickets
and they would be lucky to simply break
even see the secret lies in their
secondary business of leasing and
selling airplanes while this is not
their main business this is a main
profit source in late 2016 Air Asia was
Airbus's second-biggest customer only
beaten by indigo in fact they had a
total of 575 planes to their name with
401 the vast majority still not being
delivered with so many planes on order
Air Asia has significant negotiating
powers with Airbus and not only that but
they are also still on the line for
other airlines to place Airbus orders as
AirAsia is already one of the leaders in
the Chinese
aviation industry they aren't very
concerned about growing their network
right now but rather getting out of the
huge negative cash flow ditch that they
have dug themselves into so as they
receive these deliveries from Airbus
they don't add a new route instead they
replace one of their old planes with a
new plane and leased out the old plane
to up-and-coming Airlines these airlines
are already losing money and can't come
up with the capital to buy their own
airplane so they turn to leasing thanks
to air Asia's huge order quantity from
Airbus they're able to lease out their
old planes for cheaper than official
leasing companies like GE Capital
aviation services at the beginning when
AirAsia started using this business
model they were able to increase her
profit after tax by one hundred eighty
seven percent in just one quarter and
it's not just Air Asia this seems to be
the general trend throughout Chinese
Airlines most Chinese leasing companies
only became involved in the market
within the last three to five years but
within this time they were able to grow
to control 15% of the world's least
aircrafts so this is where the select
Chinese airlines that are profitable
make a profit while selling tickets for
under market value and paying past
double-standard income and airlines that
aren't able to jump onto this business
model or diversify their income in other
ways well they won't last very long as
they compete in the cutthroat Asian
market but that is what I think if you
guys thought this video explained the
Chinese air industry well and would like
to help more people see this video they
make you drop a like and make sure to
subscribe if they see more question just
like this one answered logically but
until then I'm hari now see you guys on
the next one